today in the world we see this very
rapid aging and other people are among
amongst the most vulnerable
subpopulation group yet they don't have
their rights covered we have UN
Convention on rights of women children
refugees immigrants disabled people and
yet the fastest growing subgroup in the
population all the people don't have the
convention to protect their rights and
their issues that have very specific
such as access to services age
discrimination we have neglect abundant
elder abuse publishers that are not
contemplated by order UN conventions so
one of the objectives is at the end of
the day have a UN Convention and a
Special Rapporteur for Human Rights that
is what we discussed in this chapter of
the book on aging to be launched it next
year 2012 by the world economic